Welcome everybody to another Zoom call. A lot of questions, so I'll jump right in with those right now, and feel free to chat at any questions as you think about along the way.
Remind you to always look at the announcements. One of the announcements last week is we had our video site was hacked by some Chinese online embolites.
Some crazy like that. Changed all our videos to their promo video. Oh my god.
The name of the dusting really.
But our whole video, whole website was messed up by all of anything that had ties.
So we got a fixed I think. So I will ask your help if you do see a video that's not played or not working if you could.
Send an email to labs at Conner's clinic and hopefully take a screen shot of that.
That would help in case there's still things that aren't working. I think we got to fix.
I had to re upload last week the Zoom call. I just did that Monday after we had an all corrected. So last week's Zoom call is back up there again.
Our video site is back working again, so.
But I did put that announcement in last week's announcement. So always look at the members that announcement.
For announcements. Okay.
First question. Hello doctor. I have decided to stop.
The immune. I think it's the Olivia immune and the blacks have bloodroot capsules dot black paste.
Black sand bloodroot capsules.
And I am.
As it seems I have gotten worse. So to me, this means they haven't been good for me.
And that begs the question like how long should you be on a product before and you reassess it.
Well, first of all, you'd ask the question.
How are you reassessing it? Are you looking at objective findings? Are you looking at solely objective findings? You're going to look at those code of things.
And how long? Let's say some people just start with the player. They're just starting with a supplement program.
They went out of three months and their cancer is continuing to spread.
Does that mean the nutritional program isn't working? Well, maybe I think it's wise to always reassess things.
But you know, when you go on something new, it takes months for things to really make a change.
So don't be too quick to make changes either about saying this question shouldn't, but just be thinking about that.
Cancer has been increasing in my bone marrow and my spine. I'm looking into starting the mistletoe program.
How do you feel about this protocol and the success of it?
And mistletoe done intravenously or done with injections can be extremely helpful.
We've had people have done it with a lot of success and we have had people that have done it and seemingly had no benefits.
It's just like anything else. So what may work for me may not work for you.
There's nothing wrong with trying something new. That's a question. I'm wondering about the medical earlier.
ASC we de risk estimator. So what that is, is that is a risk estimator for cardiovascular disease.
Are you familiar with it? Yes, I'm familiar with it. It's a you put in your parameters of your cholesterol and I don't know some different blood parameters.
It's an age of your weight and your blood pressure and such. And it gives you a risk factor.
Is that what's your thoughts about it? Take it on the risk factors. It appears that I might be very, very high risk.
I'm working to make lifestyle changes. I welcome any info.
There's a lot more than just the risk factors that are in this little online questionnaire that you could fill out.
So is cholesterol a factor in cardiovascular? Yes, if cholesterol is extremely high, it can be a factor.
What's a greater factor in my blood work than cholesterol that they don't even ask you this. I don't think they ask it. That's triglycerides.
They don't ask for triglycerides and triglycerides is really your number one cardiovascular risk blood profile that you get in a normal, not in depth, but a normal blood workup.
Now you could do an in depth cardiovascular blood workup where you're testing for like oxidative lipid particles that can be and show increased risk for cardiovascular things.
But when you get down to the most common sources that are causes of cardiovascular risk, you're looking at Hpilora, you're looking at heavy metals, you're looking at Lyme disease, you're looking at other toxins.
So working on detoxification, working on dealing with Hpilora, even if you don't have other signs of Hpilora, treated as if you have Hpilora, and getting your blood pressure down if you do have high blood pressure because that can be a risk for cardiovascular disorders.
I do have a whole series on cardiovascular disorders in my blog post because I actually did an entire course of cardiovascular number of years back.
And there's other blood factors that you can take to measure cardiovascular risk like interleukin six is a good one test to measure cardiovascular risk.
Now I know both standard medical doctors are really going to just look at cholesterol, HDL and LDL cholesterol as you're made cardiovascular risk factors and then they're going to put person as elevated cholesterol on a lipitor type product that's going to lower your cholesterol and you think that you have a lower cardiovascular risk and if you did an online risk estimator like this, it would show that you're in a lower risk factor.
But you're really not people that lower their cholesterol artificially with statin drug doesn't actually lower their cardiovascular disease risk because you're basically just artificially lowering cholesterol because cholesterol is not the culprit in cardiovascular disease.
It's damaged to the arterial walls sometimes by elevated almost 60 levels sometimes, like I said, by Hpilora or Lyme disease or heavy metal toxicity that's affecting the endothelial because that's the inner lining of the vessels when you have damaged endothelial cells that that's what cholesterol can plaque on even below cholesterol will still plaque on that.
Do I give much credence to this risk estimator? No, because it's really not taking it into fact or the real causes of cardiovascular disease and dealing with those so I'm going to discuss it further with you specifically I'm going to do that.
Next question, I searched the blog for info info and products in your store recipe is it safe to assume that taking collagen is safe for all cancer patients.
I would say no, I think I think this question was asked last week or the week before this collagen saved for cancer.
And the answer is yes and no, so it depends on where you are with your cancer, your cancer is very active and growing I would say no, you want to be, you want to be overly concerned with any possible growth risk factors.
If your cancer is currently at bay and it's really hasn't done much and I really would like to take some collagen for my hair or skin or nails, I would say there's nothing wrong with taking collagen.
There is one caveat on collagen is that it isn't that uncommon to have antibodies against collagen, so I also see a number of people with autoimmune disorders.
And we test in the Syrex Array 5, one of the things that that tests for is antibodies, tests for antibodies to a number of different self tissues and one of the self tissues that a test scores collagen and it's not that uncommon to have antibodies to collagen.
So that's what could give a person a lot of joint pain, you know, you hear about people with Lyme disease that have, you know, joint pain that moves around and and.
You hear people with with arthritis and they have joint pain and they're they think because they have a diagnosis of rheumatoid arthritis or psoriatic arthritis or even degenerative arthritis that it's because of the the arthritis meeting the joint itself that they have pain but many times when you do an antibody test it's they may also actually have rheumatoid factors.
Well, but they may have antibodies to collagen, so where's collagen found in your body and spotted your joint capsules and spawned in your ligaments, your tendons, it's found in any connective tissue, which is good to say it's everywhere so it's like one of the worst thing is to have antibodies against because you know when when you're immune system will flare you could have pain literally anywhere.
So you like I said with a lot of Lyme patients stay in Lyme is the bacteria is long gone, but what it left them was antibodies to self tissue and if it's antibodies to collagen, they can get these weird pains anywhere.
So they do anything and step off the curve rather than these feels like it's broken so if you have any type of symptoms like that, we wear a collagen so those people if you do have anybody's college or you can't take exogenous college and you're just going to make things way worse.
But while I take college and before it's never maybe feel worse, well, then I think you're safe, so then you fall into the category and all my cancers kind of at bay, you know, it's not growing or anything I feel like I'm doing well and I just want to freeze my nails and my skin and my feel better with my joints, then I don't think there's anything wrong with taking it but.
Just be aware of that next question with the visible light work for my basal cell and my lump.
So the viso light is a superficial light therapy it's not right light therapy that's going through your tissues and deep through your body it's going to work on skin and work on superficial things so would the viso light be good for basal cell yeah it would be it would actually good be good for melanoma it would be good for squamous cell and be good for surface cancers be good for surface wounds.
But it'd be good for my lump well if it's very near the surface because it's only going to go a few millimeters deep so probably not I don't know it'd be really if he.
But certainly for any basal cell cancer any any surface cancer any surface wounds you know there's argument with different light therapy like red light therapy red light therapy so good for you well.
Well they're taking a lot of the research that they're using to justify the benefits of red light therapy from from things that are going much deeper so.
Hey is the red light therapy good for well yes it is but don't think it's going to have necessarily.
Benefits to different organs others arguments that well if you affect the surface you have this reflex change in the organ tissue well i'll give you that plus if you affect the surface you're affecting from a neurological standpoint the brain that can affect other tissue i'll give you that too so you can't deny that any type of there's closet effect when you do positive things on the surface of your skin that it's.
Effective the rest of your body yes there's truth to that so i am never against any of the red light therapy or blue light therapy or red light therapy or anything visibly allows you to use the multiple different lights and it is the best I think light therapy machine on the market.
So I think it's a great tool and yeah that would be something you could use for anything skin related and it does reflexively and neurologically affect other organs as well how long should I be doing my right and my supplements i am doing so much better.
i'm doing so much better what's hard to say like oh i'm doing so much better my cancers and remissions so i'm going to stop doing the things that got me in revision that's not always wise thing to do so.
You know what and years ago i wouldn't emphasize that very much meaning i wouldn't put so much stress on a person to keep doing their right to keep doing the nutrition and and i saw the negative results of that remember you know people coming back into what i had a clinic and and their cancer came back and they haven't used their right for years.
I just had somebody you know recently sent the avenues their right for five years and now their cancers come back well would it have come back if they were still using the right but still taking their supplements well we don't know those answers to those questions it just makes sense to me to continue to do the things that got you into the state of remission in the first place especially if it doesn't take much time.
Next question how much does my attitude affect my cancer really.
I think that's how much does my cancer how much does my attitude really affect my health or my cancer well i think it affects your body a lot.
If you're talking about just a good attitude bad attitude happy crabby you know i think there's a lot of biblical reference to be grateful.
And you know be you know there's a lot of new agey kind of positive mental attitude stuff but really you could argue that it is grounded deeply as well.
I wouldn't say that there's any biblical stance that if you just have a good attitude everything's going to be good but it does tell us typically that we're supposed to be grateful and thankful for everything in the fruits of the spirit our love joy piece patients goodness kindness.
Gratefulness self control are these are all outward acts the fruit of the spirit is the fruit that comes from a tree that's grounded in God so if we're grounded in our father in our heavily father then we're going to bear good fruit so I guess I would say that our attitude is the fruit of what we're grounded in.
So if I am you know I have a day that I'm grabbing an angry which I have a lot of days like that I have to look at what am I holding on to is it to situate is it my positive situation that's going to make me happy or am I am I rounded in my relationship with Jesus Christ through Jesus Christ to my heavenly father that's going to give me joy that's going to bear the fruit.
And that we call our attitude you know when I am a bad attitude I got to look at where where my groundedness is am I am I really grafted into the tree of our heavenly father that's the question I have to ask myself when we need to all be introspective enough and we need to all have.
Close enough friends and in loved ones in our life that can slap us a little bit and we need to all not take offense when we do have someone in our life that loves us enough to slap us a little bit to remind us of where we're supposed to be grafted into and grounded into and so that we will produce the fruit of the spirit in our lives.
And that's that's what accountability is and that's what you know spiritual maturity is is you know I said many times spiritual maturity isn't not sitting it's that we are more quickly convicted of our sin in our bad attitude and more quickly repent of that of that bad attitude.
And and and bring and come back into submission to our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ so the more I the longer I take to come back into submission to my to my Lord is a sign of less maturity as I mature doesn't mean I'm not going to screw up more and have a bad attitude and be frammy it means that I'll be convicted.
And more quickly and be able to come back into submission of that helps next question.
You know anyone doing whole body hyperthermia with success.
I don't we've had patients over the years that have gone to Germany because that's really the only place you could do a whole body hyperther.
There's some German cancer clinics now quite honestly I don't know how and how successful they've been and even keeping their doors open years ago.
The choice of getting alternative cancer was to come to a clinic that was daring to step out like we were 20 years ago doing what we were doing and we were being bombarded by the medical profession.
There wasn't very many clinics in the United States as you know one is there are now doing anything alternative in the United States.
I wanted to do something like if you looked at whole body hyperthermia the German cancer clinics were very popular into that the Mexico cancer clinics were not doing any whole body hyperthermia.
Clearly I don't know if those German clinics are even still open I know that German medical association has you know since COVID has gone much more Western.
So I don't even know if those places still exist and that's where people received this therapy in the past I understand whole body hyperthermia is you're going into this like God.
And you're you're being you have an IV tube in you and you're basically being completely sedated in order to do this because you're trying to get your your core body temperature up to a fever state of 105 to 107 there's no way you would be able to tolerate that without being sedated.
And that's for a long period of time anywhere between 4 to 8 hours it's just it's a very intense and can be dangerous.
There's no clinics in the US there were doing that to my knowledge no clinic still that are doing anything like that.
So I don't know of anybody who's done the whole body hyperthermia or doing it.
What could be the problem if I'm having headaches after I eat.
Well headaches after you eat could be a lot of things I mean anytime you have a headache the first thing you think of is inflammation so.
You can have a muscular inflammation can be causing a headache so there can be vascular headaches there can be intercredial inflammation that can be causing a headache.
You can have cervical neck subluxations that can be causing a headache so there's a lot of causes for headaches when you think no it's all I don't know is it only after you eat I mean if there's only after you eat you could think of anything that's causing inflammation in your gut.
That's causing inflammation in the brain so like I said inflammation the gut is going to cause inflammation the brain was one and one so there anything you're eating that's causing inflammation the gut.
And it doesn't have to be a sensitivity quote of quote that's something that's irritating the gut that's causing inflammation that's what I would think.
That's a first thing I would think is try to narrow down what it is that you're eating that is doing that.
Now if it's anything you eat it's good to say anything I eat causes this then I would say you just have general inflammation the gut and I would go take a step back and start doing some gut healing protocol that's what sunscreen and the FBI protect can be very beneficial for that.
Next question I've been experiencing severe hot flashes at night especially along with all the other nasty metaposal symptoms.
I saw in that Christy Northrop has a product called a rope a botan made with an herb called mereria.
I can't pronounce that sorry are you familiar with this herb and if so is it okay to take with hormone positive breast cancer.
I am not taking black cohash or astro clear only your other product with dim and calcium degluterate.
I am familiar with that or even though I can't pronounce it and it has been used for people with hot flashes and the reason why it can help is it can stimulate estrogen production in your adrenal glands.
Now if you have hormone positive breast cancer that's not what you want to do it would probably help with hot flashes.
As well as black cohash can help with hot flashes but the whole purpose of trying to the whole purpose in measuring whether you have a hormone positive cancer and trying to treat it as a help to reduce your cancer is to reduce estrogens.
And if you're taking something that will increase your estrogens and thereby decrease the severity of the hot flashes no matter how unpleasant they may be you're kind of going against what you're trying to do for the breast cancer so I guess I can't recommend that.
You know there may be other doctors that know estrogens have nothing to do I don't care if you're estrogen positive breast cancer estrogen nothing to do with it.
I know doctors who even give a prescription for hormone replacement therapy to people who have hormone positive cancer to me that makes no sense whatsoever.
And I would never do that so you're welcome to do what you want to do but I wouldn't do anything that's going to increase your estrogens and I never experience hot flashes so I apologize for not taking into consideration the emotional issues of the hot flash but your whole purpose is trying to slow the cancer.
Regarding burberry I saw on your website that there are different a couple different kinds of burberry what's the best type of burberry to take.
Okay so for years and years and years the only type of burberry was burberry hydrochlorine I think it was called.
95% of the products the burberry products of the market will contain that.
About two years ago it was discovered that burberry die hydro what is it called burberry die hydro burberry I think it's called the HP is them is is literally in all the studies five times more bio.
Available meaning that you had you could absorb it and it works five times better than the burberry day sale so.
We we started carry that as a private label there's only a couple of companies that you can get it from we started carry it as a private label is burberry clear throw we still have the burberry clear with the old burberry.
When we switched all our patients to the burberry clear roll because okay so if you're taking.
Three of 500 milligram capsules of the old burberry which again 95% of the burberry in other markets that are all burberry it's still very good for you but if you took five.
You took three the same equivalent dosage of the burberry row it would literally have five times more benefit or you could literally if you only wanted that smaller dose you could take less of it so it is the same price that's the weird thing so.
So it's the burberry clip pro is the product that we would recommend regarding the black sand bloodroot capsules in an effort to clear the breast cancer that has possibly spread is it okay or safe to increase the dosage and take more than three a day.
So the black sand bloodroot capsules somebody has a question about that last week or the week before two.
And I said that I wish they would have deemed it something different because it isn't black sand but it doesn't bloodroot in it it has gravioly in it it has burdock in it it has chaperone in it these are all four very positively known herbs for helping kill cancer.
Can you take more than three a day yes could you offer dose of this well you could overdose on anything but you know you could I mean a person could take probably up to 12 a day probably take way more than that you're still not at any sort of a half of the lethal dose or anything like that I don't know there is a lethal dose of these herbs but you couldn't give you a tummy ache or something maybe.
So yes you could increase the dose of that if you feel like God has leading you to it I think there's I think that there's just a mixture of those four herbs in it I mean you compare that with like other like like oxy so oxy is another known cancer killer it also has burdock it has some different.
It's like red clover and Oregon grape which is burberry and licorice which is mainly used to help heal the God and then you compare that to like seac so what herb seac is another blended product it's a blended herb that has burdock root it has a.
A sheep sorrow in it and slippery elm which is typically slippery elm is used just to help heal the God it has Indian rhubarb so you notice some similarities in these different herbs i think I shared.
A couple of questions a few weeks ago about burdock root burdock rose I mean I got enough burdock growing in my yard to probably.
You know help every cancer person patient on the planet if they let it take burdock it is a great herb for cancer that's a common herb in all three of those formulas so yes you could take more.
Regarding the greens first pro product you recommended that i am taking I also ordered the capsules are the capsules as effective or absorbed as much as the powder made into a smoothie well i i would say they're absorbed as unless you have major stomach problems where you have sensitivity to capsules.
If you know some people would rather take things in a powder and liquid form and where the sake of just maybe it absorbs better there's never been a study on any of these things so I don't know you're just kind of guessing but.
You know if a person's taking too many capsules that can the capsule product itself can be an irritant to the God.
If that's never bothered me at all and it's not easier for me just to swallow a capsule and by all means take the capsules I am both the powder in the capsule at home and I tend to use the capsules myself just because it don't feel like mixing up a smoothie and i'm too much in a hurry in my life to do that so.
I hear you I understand why you want to use capsules I don't think you have any less absorption so.
I've been searching for something to take or do to help a severe burning pain I get in my thighs when I walk nothing is helped the pain either strong narcotics or any supernatural i'm suspicious that it could be from the bartonella that I have.
Would it be okay to try each box to see if that would help with both the breast cancer.
Diagnosis as well as Lyme and co infections possibly help with the wrong awful birdie pain of my thighs absolutely so you could for sure there there is no.
Conter indication that age bot or cancer any type of cancer i would also consider running the bartonella program the right.
During the day think about that if that is an issue run the pain program of the right run other Lyme co infections on the right see if that makes a difference as well.
Is be said is might it would be 17 or it's also called leotra okay to take with horrible positive breast cancer yes that's okay to take a.
Now that's something that you can will be on so make sure that you don't take too much of that.
Is it possible to not need to run my cancer program every night i know i am sensitive to too much detox at one time past experience that taught me of course i would need to do everything i can to might keep the cancer at bay.
Um yeah i mean if your cancer isn't like glowy right now and you want to run a different program tonight for some other reason then by all means yeah run something else for sure.
Questions from the chat.
In regards to the mosaic diagnostics like otox test directions it states to avoid the following for at least three days prior to collecting.
Ludothial charcoal bentonite clay and similar binders with the key to clear bay zero be considered a similar binder that i should avoid for three days yes well the key to clear is.
The key to clear is technically more key later but there's things in there that would be considered binders as well so i would stay just to be safe stay off that for three days beforehand.
Well H bot H bot is hyperbaric hyperbaric their oxygen therapy caused herxine for late stage lime.
Um no it shouldn't because H bot isn't.
Isn't isn't really going to cause death to line bacteria H bot is going to increase oxygenation of your blood.
That will help with your brain and inflammation i don't.
Anything is possible with lime you know so it's hard you can't just say oh no not has you know i've treated up line patients in any any game so.
If you're going to do H bot I would say start slow I know typically at H bot a session starts at an hour you can start at 15 minutes just wherever you're going for H bot see if you can start with shorter sessions to see how you tolerate.
Alright well thanks for being on today everybody you guys have a blessed.
Day we have a rainy fuller day but it's very welcomed as we were in the 90s last three days so it's another early morning.
If you guys have a blessed day and we will talk again next week.
Bye bye.